[Music]
[Music]
welcome everybody to this event where we
um
honor and and celebrate
um the life of jing wong who was a
wonderful colleague and friend and to
everybody i think in this room and many
of the folks online as well
um i'm eric popper i'm the head of
comparative media studies and writing
i'm just going to sort of give a brief
introduction to
james chronology at mit
introduce the speakers that we're going
to have today um at the end of the
session there will be a chance for
everybody um both in the room and online
to participate as well and contribute
their thoughts um
and the ways that jamie influenced their
lives and their careers as well
king was the nsc fung
uh professor of chinese languages and
culture um and a long-time member of the
mit faculty
um you know she contributed in many ways
to the lives of everybody in this room
as a teacher
as a mentor as a scholar
as an inspiration
jim joined the faculty in 2001 as a
professor in foreign languages and
literature
um
she was a head of foreign languages and
literature from 2005 to 2008.
um she joined the cmsw or cms at the
time
as a colleague eventually as a joint
appointment um and in 2019 is her
primary appointment as well
in 2011 uh jim was appointed as the sc
fong professorship i'm working the
douglas fong who is joining us uh this
evening as a representative of the fong
family um and they generously
established the essie fong chair
translation culture uh in 1992. we
appreciate that
uh the family is joining us today and to
share their respects and appreciation of
jinx's contributions
uh jane was a tireless mentor
scholar
uh
both fighting for folks on campus um and
around the world um she was a pioneer in
the field of chinese studies um and uh
inspiration uh for for scholars uh in in
this area all around the world
um
uh we were sad when ching passed away
this summer um at the age of 71 this
past july um and today as globally and
we publicly honor her life and work and
will feature four brief talks um from
some of the people who knew her best and
they include
civilizations in mit history and the
director of global languages
uh t.l taylor who is professor of
empowered media studies at mit and
co-founder of any key
uh han soo who's the founder and ceo of
pivochain and finally tammy barlow who's
with george and nancy ruff professor of
humanities at rice university and then
uh jane in 1986 at duke
uh with that i will
so good afternoon everyone it's really
my privilege to be able to be here to
remember my dear colleague
brilliant
critical thinker
visionary
rigorous committed indispensable
fierce intellect
fearless
kind warm caring fighter
lovely person
politically engaged activist
funny
complicated
a peach
concern for justice anti-elitist trusted
ally
teacher mentor advocate loving mother
true friend
generous
these are just some of the list of words
that i heard from people at mit and far
beyond
in those very long days following her
death in july
but for me there is a single word that
sums it up for jing
irreplaceable
jing was born in taiwan in may 1950 very
soon after the chinese nationals retreat
to taiwan in december of 1949.
her family was part of the mass exodus
of mainland chinese following the
communist revolution and i believe that
this experience of exile and
displacement shaped
life in profound
up
ways
she belonged neither to the local
taiwanese community nor to the
mainlander elites that dominated timely
politics and society during that time
in an interview for cms in 2013
jane described her experience as the
daughter of a sea captain and a
housewife
she said it was very very difficult
being lower middle class back then
i believe that her anti-elitism and her
concern for justice grew from these
experiences
jing also learned to become a fighter
as was common for chinese girls during
this era she faced the preference for
sons over daughters
the inherent gender bias and confucian
culture and she dedicated her life to
finding this injustice
in fact at the time of her death she was
serving on the shash gender equity
committee and committee chair professor
chris capizzola remembers her as one of
the more active committee members okay
for those of you who served on a
committee with jing you know exactly why
active
as a child of refugees
as a girl in a male-dominated society
jing turned her energy passion and
brilliance to academic pursuits
she attended the top university in
taiwan taiwan national university
majoring in the prestigious foreign
languages department
her classmates recall to me how she sean
in the classroom asking the most
perceptive questions giving the most
thoughtful astute responses and critical
readings
but her concern her pursuits at this
time were always constrained in taiwan
in the 1950s and 60s due to the fact
that it was under martial law
there was no freedom of speech
no freedom of the press
no freedom of assembly
no freedom to organize
even for a scholar of a subject perhaps
seemingly apolitical such as comparative
literature there were constraints on the
books you could read
on the theory you could study
on the words you could write
so jing's keen interest in marx's theory
and criticism that developed later in
her life really must be understood
against this background of repression
life essentially all elite students in
taiwan at that time she came to the
united states for graduate study during
the 1970s
she earned her phd in comparative
literature from the university of
massachusetts amherst
and
her dissertation advisor lucian miller
still fondly remembers her as one of the
most brilliant students he has ever
taught
leaving behind the constraints of taiwan
jing found herself
uh you know horizons opening wide before
her
and she explored very widely and
voraciously embarking on what would
become her wide range of intellectual
journey
constantly challenging herself to learn
more
experience more
write more
coming from martial law taiwan jane
found the freedoms of american academia
and democracy precious
and to the end of her life she was a
staunch defender of free speech
academic freedom and democracy
one thing that always stood out to me
about jing was that she was fiercely
proud to be an american
she was also fiercely critical of the
ways in which america failed to live up
to its promise
and as ken has asked me to remind
everybody
jing was a staunch advocate for racial
justice for all groups
and in this last two years she was
deeply concerned about anti-chinese
sentiment anti-asian violence and the
targeting of scientists of chinese
descent
especially after our own professor
gangshan's arrest last year
following her phd june spent three years
at middlebury college and then joined
the faculty at duke where she taught for
16 years before coming to mit
and she then quickly became a highly
valued leader in chinese studies as well
as in cms as eric has already mentioned
a recognized pioneer in the field of
china studies jing earned accolades for
her scholarship on the chinese
literature
culture and media
never content to rest on her laurels and
perpetually driven by her intellectual
curiosity
jing changed her area of specialization
and methodological approaches numerous
times over the decades and this i think
is one of the key challenges and even
trying to begin to think about replacing
jing right she is truly
irreplaceable
beyond traditional academic pursuits jin
gave her talents and energy to a highly
innovative endeavor the non-profit ngo
2.0 which she launched with chinese
collaborators in 2009 to help chinese
grassroots organizers use social media
to be change agents and i believe there
will be more
information on that this evening
i want to end by noting what a dedicated
teacher jing was
she taught a broad spectrum of classes
and she was even developing a new class
on romance and chinese fiction that she
never had the opportunity to teach
since her death many of her former
students have reached out to me to tell
me of the deep impact she had on them
and i know what a transformative teacher
she was because she was also my teacher
jing left this world as a teacher
on the sunday morning of her untimely
death
jing was teaching a class
in china on zoom
and i keep this image because to me it's
so quintessentially jing
just irreplaceable
thanks emma it was so nice it's funny
because over the years i've heard you
know you hear stories from your friend
about their life and trajectory and you
just put it together wonderfully and
thank you so much for sharing all that
my remarks are going to be a little more
extemporaneous
um
and a little less on her her
intellectual life and more my experience
of jing as a friend which i i know she
wants to so many here
um i was thinking about the first time i
met jing and it's funny when you go
somewhere for a job you know it's like
three days or whatever two days of
worldwide meetings and
but i yet i have a very clear memory of
jing that visit i came here of this very
petite woman sitting at the back of the
room and when q a came after my lecture
she sort of leaned forward i think she
had you know pad in hand
and asked this really terrific question
and for those who don't know me i do
stuff on gaming i think at the time i
was just finished an esports book i mean
so
in some ways orthogonal and she was just
there and i just i remember that and so
my first experiences of jane here were
as a colleague and
serving with her on committees
and the just the diligence and the care
sometimes the needed ferocity
just the commitment she had i i was
looking back through emails
over the years i've had with her and
there was one where when i was going up
for full professor
she had like line edited my personal
statement with just like these
really careful thoughtful and i just it
was you know
it was it's such a generosity to give
people and things that kind of attention
and it just when i think of jing as a
colleague it's it's such a defining
feature of her i would say too as a
colleague
she was always so committed to keeping
our larger vision conversations going
whether it's our grad program or who we
were going to be as a department in the
future
so i think you know i first came to know
her as a colleague
um
and in that way one of the things i was
also struck with always with jing is the
vibrancy the vibrancy of her intellect
of her spirit of her engagement with
everything
um
[Music]
once i think she got a handle on kind of
what i did
she was always sending me links
links to esports articles links to live
streaming looks to gaming here's a
connection in china just you know
the generosity of also recognizing in
the other what they're interested in and
finding ways to connect with them
through that
um is something i think of so jing an
email that says check your wechat and
then you go to wechat because she's
found something on wechat that you need
to take a look at
um
so i count i count myself really lucky
to have had her as a colleague it's
where we get colleagues that we
you know have
that we value so much and have those
connections with
um but over time i i really came to
more so value my friendship with her um
and i i think a couple of people heard
this story but
for me it's it sort of sums up so much
of jing in so many ways i remember the
first time she invited me to dinner at
her house which i'm sure some of you
have done before
and at the time i was living at a dorm
here on campus in simmons i didn't have
a car
and so she invited my partner and i
mickey and so we got a zip car and you
know you reserve a zip car okay you know
seven to ten
no
we went to jing's house for dinner and
of course jing is rolling she's a mate
she was an amazing cook
amazing cook and in a you know former
life she had actually kind of had a
restaurant i think and
yeah
um so she's just rolling out course
after course
and we're realizing oh my god it's
almost 10 and we are still in this
and i try to adjust the
the uh reservation and i can't we have
to leave and she's like what
we still have three courses to go
horrified lesson learned of course she
piled it all up in
take away you know whatever she had she
gave us boxes to go and i learned if you
go for dinner with jane you are having a
real dinner that's going to last hours
and be filled with amazing food and
conversation
and if it wasn't at her house
one of the other last times i got to eat
with her
i she took me to dim sum and when we
were we happened to be in new york city
at the same time dim sum
with jing was
amazing because all of that kind of
knowing what she wanted knowing how to
make it best for everyone and you know
getting us all the right food just
wonderful that bonding over food was for
me such a classic
thing and i think a lot of folks over
the years who experienced her generosity
she would often open up her home
to students who were here over the
holidays and invite them over for meals
when everybody else was going off and
just that kindness extended
the other thing i just wanted to mention
something
um
i loved about her was the
kind of con you know the calls and the
commiserations and the talking and
those of you know me know i love my
leisure time
i have a lot of hobbies and
jing and i respectively teased each
other about this
because you know she did her there she
had her hobbies but she was focused on
her hobbies and i often joked with her
that you know i would if i could i would
retire now but she would still be
working 20 years from now
and you know she just constantly had new
projects and was constantly engaged
i talked to her the day before she died
and we had
she had
again very generously brought me into
one of her networks in china and we were
on a project there and going to go over
there together and she was you know this
excitement about this next new thing
that she was doing um
i was always amazed by her energy
could often not keep up even when we
were walking but she was a
dynamic vibrant
deeply loving
person um
and
well it's a lost step
for a colleague she's i think those of
us who knew her something also other
than a colleague it's a tremendous loss
that care so
that's it it's very pity to meet you
guys here
um for me uh professor william
is
uh another founder of ngo 2.0
and also my mentor
um she
passed away all of a sudden
and
i was actually uh
in the meeting
in the morning she was
uh having
with the ngo 2.0 uh
colleagues
and all of a sudden
we saw the message
um she passed away on facebook but i was
very shocked i thought it's fake but
sadly is true
yeah she's not just my mentor
in terms of academia but also
for life for
career
and a lot of things so i remember the
first time like during the orientation
she everyone was asked to show a picture
of themselves
um she showed her avatar which is also
the avatar i first
saw when i sent the first email to her
it's a it's like a super
woman in the
game
uh it's a super woman with a sword on
her back
um
i was when i was when i was sending the
email i was wondering that she played a
lot of video games
um
she liked that avatar
i think um she has a sense of
uh being a super woman
as
a
someone in this world
and
she has that sense of justice in my
opinion
meanwhile she is a
she believes in buddhism if you guys
don't know so in buddhism it's like you
don't need to do
a lot of things you just
let it be
so it's sort of antithetical to
his to her
way of devotion to her life and
i was very curious on why she worked so
hard in the very beginning but as i uh
as i got to know her better i realized
i think it's her sense of justice she
has a critical lens towards a lot of
things
and when she believes there is injustice
she tries to
change it
so
um yes
um
other people uh
i understand she she loves uh cooking
and she loves
eating um
in different restaurants the first piece
of information she shared with me was
hey market in boston
and some hidden gems
chinese restaurants in chinatown she
also
invited me and other friends to
different restaurants
from time to time
she
she she has a very good taste in a lot
of things especially food
she uh once i was
eating at a restaurant she recommended
me uh not with her but i bumped into her
so i was
uh it's not
it's not unexpected at all so i know
shishu would be at those different
restaurants
and she also cooked
very well very professionally and she
invited me and iago to her house
during thanksgiving since we were the
only two international students
there and we don't have a place to go so
it was a very good experience
i remember there was a dish
called
um it's a chinese dish but i've never
seen that dish she said it's
vegan
fish so i was wondering what the hell
how could the fish be vegan and so so
she explained she learned that dish from
a chinese chef
migrated from mainland china to taiwan
and that dish is lost in men in china
and that's why i haven't ever
tried that fish
in before
in my life
she was pretty proud of that she maybe
she was the only person who could
could have made that dish
um and later on
in summer 2019
um we
met in beijing back in china um
i remember i was
inviting her to
something with me in china i was saying
uh in in the u.s you treat me so now
you're in china maybe i should treat you
and she was like no no
um you're still a student maybe when you
become rich or when you work you treat
me
that's very very unfortunate
unfortunately i
don't have a chance anymore
she is
she has a very strong sense of justice
um as i mentioned she
i think she started ngo 2.0
um not all of a sudden
but
before that she was doing work she was
ahead of creative commons
of china or of asia as well but she
found um creative commons is
to be found is not useful to most of
the chinese citizens
it's a design
still in the
ivy
power
so it's
not helping a lot of
chinese people
so
when
information is
even today
there are still half of the chinese
people
living in a standard of
less than 200 usd per month
so
almost half a billion more than half a
billion people still leaving
laser with less than 200 usd per month
in china so she understands that
something like creative commons won't
directly help those chinese people
and i think she
doesn't want to
get involved into
political power or money too much she
still wants to
really empower those people who really
need her help
so she decided to
do something that will empower the local
governmentalities
organizations that's the social
organizations back in china
and her method is to use um to provide
technical solutions to those local ngos
as an ngo themselves ngo 2.0 so it's
called ngo 2.4 because web 2.0 is to
let everybody to participate to the web
so android partner is to use technical
solutions to empower every social
organizations in china to
communicate to
marketing
so she has
she's very proud of her practice
practical
um
experience
apart from her
success in academia so
think she understands how to
really change the
so-called change the world it's not just
writing
i think she has two
ways to change the world one is to
directly
help
use her power to empower others the
other is to communicate
to different people
of her
through her writings her books
so she when i was writing the studies
she said um if you read something you
have to
make it valuable
by letting different people
read your
work so if you re if you write something
that no one will
really read and it's not
valuable at all so
i think she understands um how to make
changes
through practice
um
and
for me uh she she actually
has nothing with to do with men in china
she was born in taiwan and then become
chinese american but she still choose to
um dedicate her
past 10 years
in the field work of melania china and
she is of course she of course she is
not a nationalist and she defines
herself as a leftist
i think she understands
what's a
true privilege
for example
nationalities one of them
and technical
um
literacy is one of them so she tries to
help those people who are
not heard not seen
through
her
um
so her different practical means
i remember
when i first visited her house
i saw two
uh very heavy
dumbbells 25 pounds i was wondering who
is using those kind of heavy
uh
dumbbells and she said if you should you
know i was a
sports woman i did a weightlifting so i
was pretty surprised
yeah but sadly she
uh had his job
when she worked out that's she
but
still i think she uh
tries to
intentionally join those weights on her
shoulder
to fight for the greater good
not just physically but also
at the
last 20 years she tries to track to to
evolve herself in the real world to
actually do as much as possible
so
even
at the last day of her life she was
still
working at the ngo 200 projects
and
even right now i still feel like
she may shoot me a message on wechat and
ask me to join some meeting to promote
to provide my opinions
i think even though shay has passed away
and
there are still a lot of things
that she has left to me
for example at least she
encouraged me to
work on my own
career or my on my own project to bring
my own
thoughts into a
a real
organization that can
work
well in that can work in this uh world
so
i after working several months i decided
to my own
company and
i think i will
carry out her
ideas and keep
fighting for the greater good
and that's my
all i want to say
thank you
all right if you guys give me just a
moment i'm going to set up a video that
i'm provided it also has some footage of
james
recently that was uh provided by mgf
being jin's older cousin my mother told
me about the ambulance is true ordinary
accomplishment when i was young
growing up i was so proud of antagine's
perseverance hard work and intellect
the first time we met auntie in person
was 2008 the year our family moved to
boston
since then we have held many family
gatherings whenever on the june's busy
schedule allowed
auntie loved to share with us
her many life experiences
from language learning grocery shopping
chinese medicine and acupuncture to her
favorite
gardening and cooking recipes
she cared about
the grandchildren very much and often
recommended the classical literature to
them i benefited from those readings too
when she learned that my youngest
daughter jessica loved cooking on the
team ordered one of her favorite
magazine for her bon appetit
i still vividly remember on the jin
saying
not only are the recipes good but the
articles are written
in excellent english
since the pandemic started last year
auntie spent more time at home and we
saw each other more often
she had a plan to slow down a bit and
spend
more time with friends and family
relatives
we had more opportunity to enjoy food
and share experience together in early
july at auntie's home she treated us
with her homemade paella
we never have thought that was the last
gathering
even though it is hard to believe our
energetic and lovely auntie is no longer
with us
anujin and i shared the passion of
gardening
a few years ago auntie gave us one of
her
plants the night
blooming the cactus
tan hua in chinese
summer is time has blooming season born
like a summer flower bone like the pure
heavenly tan
i pray that auntie is eternally hyping
in heaven and the dress in peace
jing was always busy
even on vacation there were things to do
questions to ask things to learn
things to teach
jean lived her life with purpose
with determination and with concern for
others
for all of her activity she was never
frantic
there was a focus in everything she did
we enjoyed meeting in new york city to
go to museums and walk in the parks
her critical eye was always busy
examining everything she saw
her tastes were modern
current
but she valued tradition in art
literature and music
she looked deeply at everything
and informed herself of what was going
on in the world through multiple lenses
she focused on what she felt was not
sufficiently understood
not critically examined not appreciated
on its own terms
i think she viewed life as an
opportunity to explore
and to make contributions
even during the darkest days of her life
she wanted to help others
to help with their grief
their loss
their frustrations
jing was never helpless
never felt sorry for herself never
stopped
every moment spent with others was an
opportunity to share
i will miss her voice her laughter
and her friendship
she was inspiring
[Music]
we're happy to start this video
as a tribute to jane
for her life and legacy
i'm miriam
and this is bruce
we want to thank jing for all of the
blessings that she has bestowed on us so
behind me you see the
red feng shui wall hanging
that she gave me
she wanted to make sure that i was
protected
and
behind us we now have the tree
go ahead
this tree
was given this by jing at candy's
passing
back in january of 2001
and the tree like jing
and everything that is connected to her
has grown better and be more beautiful
and more memorable for us as we enjoy
her presence through nature even when we
cannot always enjoy her presence in
person
and so as we think of her today and we
give thanks for everything that she gave
us
we also want to give her back this small
but very sincere tribute for everything
that she's done
may she and candy find each other and
move beyond the bardo into enlightenment
with all our love
love our love and with
every hope that this
this recording and everything else
that's done on jin's behalf
will reach her and continue to be
beneficial for us in years and years to
come
thank you jane thank you candy goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
huh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
b
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
she is a female avenger
and chain created this avatar when she
was experimenting with second life then
we all know that whenever jane was
starting something new she would call
your own phone and say guess what
and this time it was
you should join
but from that she came up with this
beautiful figure of the female avatar
and she used that ever after i was asked
to speak a little bit about her
intellectual
achievements
um i met jane uh in my first
academic um
[Music]
conference i was so agreed to the
profession that i didn't realize you had
to be invited to these things
[Music]
at the end and i thought oh i have some
trouble money i think i'll go to durham
this looks really interesting it's about
sharing home so that's how i met jean
who was then
um i think that kenny was just a living
child
in any case we really bonded in the way
that many of you bonded with jing and we
begin our
work together
um
in 1992 she won the joseph levinson
prize for the best
work
in traditional chinese studies and i
need to underscore how difficult that
was not just because jin was brilliant
and
the book is magnificent
but the idea of a young
beautiful chinese woman
winning an academic prize
was so startling that i can remember
sitting while she received the prize and
thinking this has never happened at the
aeas before
and she made it very clear that she was
from taiwan
so it was extremely important but there
was something about that book which made
it astounding that she would win a prize
because what she did basically was a
critic's devastating critique
she managed to take something absolutely
phenomenal traditional muscles and turn
it into something really deeply exciting
by seeing things there that other people
have not seen so as others have
mentioned gene never
tried to sing that twice so immediately
uh four years later she came out with
high culture fever now for me that was a
really formative book because it was at
the time
um
the subtitle is politics aesthetics and
ideology in guns china not only did
were we as a generation jake was born
five months after me and we were both
double white tigers
astrologically so we had a great deal of
comment in that way too
um
we were beginning to meet the people who
were responsible for the cultural fever
that led up to the political events of
1989
and so
through her and with her and in these
expanding networks that are the great
pleasure of being involved in chinese
intellectual life
and many of the other major actors
his book had tremendous tremendous
impact on my generation because we were
the same age and we had lived through
cultural revolution times so the
exhilaration
of the 1980s was reminiscent of the
mapworks movement the other great
uh enlightenment movement in china and
we got to participate
um
now she moved again
uh
14 years later after the
politics of
chinese politics
to which we all have a rather
difficult relationship
she began a new project
or she published her 2010 book brand in
china which looked at advertising media
and commercial culture i believe that
this was her way of entering the
methodological challenge of studying and
eliminating their culture she was
devoted as as then as emma pointed out
it wasn't just that she was an adventure
she also was devoted to showing that
popular culture had as much depth as
elite culture and that she was
conversant in both traditions that she
could enjoy and explore and explain both
the high and the
and the world i just had to put it that
way um
she began
her skills as a methodologist
of popular sociology i would say that in
this respect she was less a historian
and more a sociologist and cultural
theorist and she began to develop her
own
singular skills as a critic
in 2019 of the long wave book the other
digital china
non-confrontational activism on the
social web
uh was released she had been talking
about this uh project for many years and
uh
you know when we saw each other in china
over food in beijing or wherever
it was always about food she was full of
ideas and thoughts about and the
unfolding of this miraculous project
that we just saw
in the team
is extremely important
and that is as the critic of none
but the critic of all
she was
uh
other stuff that's testified ferociously
critical but in a disarming way i think
that
her politics of scholarship and in
personal life
and in the public sphere
were all about displacement
it was never about critique she really
didn't have much time for people who
grandstanded about critique or forwarded
their favorite pet theory uh
post-socialism post-modernism
in china and so on and so on she was
rather devastated privately about this
kind of pretension
but she was herself wrenchingly
critical and
her
merit pursuing activity intellectually
was to pay back i think
to show that
you can be critical
so long as you displace
the current conjunction as long as you
point out where the problem is and
provide solutions and to me that's what
ngo
0.20 2.0 is all about it says
yeah chinese government is pretty scary
but like chinese friends will say to you
chinese government has always been
really scary so what's new
the question was not so much to to
exhaust the ways in which the chinese
government wants
so much as reaching people
technicians
business people
vocal activists
local people marketers branders
business women
with investment possibilities to put all
these people into a rather peculiar
mixture
out of which a social movement was
born
these are her
achievements as a militant scholar
i want to talk a little bit about the
flavor
of jane's intellect
that is after all how we met and why we
stayed so close to each other
is intellectual
uh joy
i think that um
she always worked
at the margin
where she had a
vision
of the whole
and their various personal reasons for
that
but she could always find the opening
where something new would come about
so she was always about
how does new come into the world
um
that said
she
she was constantly looking and
constantly opening up the possibility i
understand her her recent
interest was in history of youth
she was always interested in what young
people have to say about their world and
how they perceive
the future possibilities because she was
always thinking in the future anterior
when this will have happened in my
lifetime i will have achieved something
is the way i understand her
intellectually
she was after all
also a long-distance runner and i was
joking with emma about how jane prepared
to write a book she started lifting
those weights she started going back to
the gym she started eating healthy and
trying to sleep we all know she wasn't
insomnia
but she trained for writing as though
she were an athlete
and she would lecture me a complete
lacie
and so on and i took it uh very
seriously and tried to do our better
stuff
there's something interesting about um
when she took her first trip to the
people's republic of china
she was writing me and saying i can't
get anything to eat
and i thought
that's simply not possible
and what it what had happened is that
she felt a sense of physical nausea
she couldn't find
the things she could eat
that would settle her stomach
um
chinese immigrants of my generation who
came to the united states that was a
common problem uh transitioning into
american food was finding uh foods that
were medically appropriate for the
transition
and um i never forgot this experience
that she shared with me about nausea
because it seems to me that this was in
some degree
a part of who she was
the world nauseated
she
it was so unkind and so deep just and so
unfair
and there's a limit to what happens
i think that she was autistic to begin
with and as she got older speaking more
profoundly
for this reason at a certain point you
do absolutely the best you can and there
is nothing that you can do to fix it
people also underestimate the violence
of her thinking
i think that jane was an intellectual
environment she could cut to the core of
things because she didn't care what that
person process this is ideas not people
she would never personalize any of this
if your idea was crap you should not see
it but we would work together to
displace that problem
that's the kind of violence that i did
on joy and that is why she has a sword
on her
i'm i'm going to be very brief in these
comments but i'm going to say to you
that i believe that she has been
massively underappreciated
as a pioneering intellectual
we know her as a very
interesting compassionate religious
woman
who loved fashion and these fingernails
are in her london
a testament to our first public
appearance together where we all regret
that
but
it's not an accident that she won a
prize
for doing something that at a point only
white men
had been rewarded for
i don't know why this book isn't taught
regularly and why there's no
historiography of this book and why
there are no students devoted to the
thought of gene
wong who of course all of you know that
her name was actually not jake
j wong is the name that she was given
by english speakers her actual name is
juan jin there's no g there's no bubble
stop it
so
she loved being american she loved
having that name and she loved being
jane walk but it's my belief that we can
do more to promote
her intellectual heritage
and give her the position and the
priorities that she earned
and you can actually follow that to say
that
story of stone is so good and taught as
a blasphemy
and first okay
thanks thanks for sharing that
all those personal tales for many years
um and uh and the
future influences of her work um
at this point i'd like to welcome
anybody in the room here or online would
like to share
any thoughts um
raise your hand virtually or in person
i'll say one quick thing
um
do we need a microphone or kind of show
yeah
these terrible eyes
i'm tom levinson and um
uh
the the dimension of her prize
uh
reminds me of when i first met jang i'd
shown up here
uh in the
in 2004 five
i i i got an office and i knew
absolutely no one
and i had no real experience of
professional academic life because
being a professor's kid is not the same
thing as being
a professor
and one day this
woman from a different then a different
department
uh
knocked on my door and uh and introduced
herself
as jing wong not wong jin
and um
and said hi
welcome to mit
and um
i'm so glad you're here because
i got the joseph levinson prize
and um
it was not
you know i'm telling you about it
because it was not an expression of
pride in her accomplishment
uh she was welcoming me and and i think
one of the things that
that um
uh i think people have already commented
on but uh
jean was a real
um
[Music]
colleague
she built departments she made
connections
and uh i think she knew
that uh
i was really adrift here
and that i was adrift in part because i
was
not really comfortable and not really
connected to the
underlying culture of academic life
and she you know talked with me for some
time on that first occasion and we would
we would talk regularly we shared
offices on the same hall for many years
and it was that sort of unequivocal
welcome and that unequivocal sense of
you know
you belong here you're you know there's
a
maybe a generational connection but it's
just you know
this is good get down to work and uh
and it's nice that we had this kind of
just
bizarre little non-connection connection
that made it possible which is what she
used to express her world
so i was grateful for that at the time
i'm still grateful
and like i think everyone here i am
still
uh disbelieving uh that
those conversations won't happen again
it's really it's really amazing that
the work that she did you know at so
many different levels throughout here
that i wasn't even aware of so
really wonderful work that she did
standpoint
hi everyone my name is marina tosi i'm a
junior undergrad here at course 15 cms
i had the pleasure along my part voters
here to take advertising and media
compare perspectives with professor
huang um spring 2020.
as an mit student often times i'm human
and
sometimes don't do all my reading for my
house classes
but never once did i miss reading for
professor wong's class
i knew she would always like cold call
on us and i could not be embarrassed in
front of her i could never let her down
because i knew she would grill me
instantly and move on to the next person
but i also did those greetings because
they were signed with like
really like good tears she knew like we
didn't want to waste our time
and
everything she did was like impactfully
full and those readings were really
interesting especially from her book
brand in china and
yeah i mean it's so cheesy to say that
her class was one of my favorites um and
i don't say that just to say it truly
was
uh willers and i worked on this group
project for the entire semester and i
remember growing up we wanted to present
just like the category for which um
i'll actually just give a little
background on the project we have to
choose a brand to reposition
um but initially we had to choose a
category and one time like category is
very broad and we were all very confused
and one time i asked my friend choose a
category and they said blue
so we were
a little bit at a loss but eventually we
decided on healthy snacks
uh we thought this presentation was
supposed to be somewhat informal we had
a few slides that we put together maybe
two hours before
and
she tore it apart like
no
sense of oh you know like we'll change
this it's like no like your stuff and
take something else
and she she did that on my slide and i
just remembered tearing up like in front
of the entire class completely
embarrassed
um but instead uh our group chose
streetwear and that was like really cool
that was really hip and we had like a
great project we really bonded as a team
um
we have like our little wechat group and
it's still
continuing and
yeah professor long is just like
incredibly great as you all know and
just like as a student my like
pause that freshman sophomore year even
when things went virtual she made things
incredibly engaging um and truly one of
the best professors
lots of lots of students who've been
impacted
over the years
we also like to share
yeah um just to say james's phone number
is still on my phone
we were conspirators uh those late night
calls uh
future big cms
she was a really trusted confidante and
uh i appreciate that a lot she was also
my introduction to china i think every
trip i've made to china
it's been a few but thanks to jane
and i think on all but one of them i was
able to meet her there which was
fantastic it meant great restaurants
we shared a passion for cultural studies
and uh english sense of it and uh
it meant walking tours to the city that
just it opened up it opened up in ways
that that
allowed me to sort of position myself
between two cultures i can't imagine
that happening with anyone else
so lots to say about her but i mean i
have to say there's no way i could think
of china um
without her just confusing all of it
ironically i've been to taiwan without
chiang and that was a
it's actually sorely mystery i really
needed that
key to open that culture
thanks william yes i i was able to
unfortunately travel to china was with
jane and
he did all the great restaurants
have many fond members
yep
i just wanted to build on this idea of
intellectual violence i really
appreciate that phrase to really capture
something
special that it's both sort of super
sharp but also somehow kind there's
kindness in the violence i was thinking
of also calls late at night i think we i
won't say who but we wrote something
collectively and she called up at 10 p.m
and said this is embarrassing grouped us
because we had
gradually
revising ways of sort of getting past uh
what sort of a fostering response would
be but actually to get what we really
were trying to say there
i found that really inspiring also
coming from a completely non-academic
family and sort of navigating my way
through just to hear her say
you know dismiss entire entire lines of
thought you know that she thought were
obsolete at this point i would just kind
of look around can you say stuff like
that
to be able to
have that kind of confidence at the same
time just kind of come across this
in a way that's not going to make people
defensive or they're going to be people
kind of shut down
um
i think that
that's something i really was inspired
by and took away from i think the last
time we met we had plans to go hiking
because there was a hill nearby where
she lives that she'd gotten lost on
trying to go up and come back down again
she'd come back got down the wrong way
and ended up in a different part of
um
that kind of challenge was something she
wasn't just gonna dismiss she's gonna
come back so we're gonna try and go up
that hill again find the right way down
and find the right path um so just that
kind of clarity on what matters what
didn't matter
i think
thanks
not hearing anybody else and we do we
have a reception after this which is
just i think outside that way i'm not
mistaken yes the
out there
where we can share each other's stories
with each other um more informally
we'll do some food and drink there as
well
so please uh
i think people don't need to scan it
again
but thank you for coming thank you for
sharing everybody
and thank you
for all the people whose lives you
touched on here and after thank you